I'm Kurt novena reading for reviewer
serial Vasquez the Paper Mario series
thrives on a clever irreverence that can
be hard to maintain its outlandish
scenarios mash the absurdist dreamlike
world of the Mushroom Kingdom and the
modernity of the real world it takes
jabs the very concepts that inspire it
knotting knowingly the audience and
whispering this whole thing is kind of
weird right it's a fun take on the
usually earnest Mario games but that
kind of slyness turns grading when the
systems that are supposed to prop it up
don't work which is where the last
couple of Paper Mario games have
struggled but in surprising
course-correction Paper Mario the
origami kings most clever trick is how
its overall combat complements its sharp
wit turning this series Achilles heel
into one of its biggest strengths
[Music]
Paper Mario the origami kings conceptual
gimmick is how its titular origami king
Ally transforms the flat cutouts of The
Paper Mario universe fooling them into
subservient 3d origami figures he
kidnaps Princess Peach along with her
entire Castle wrapping both up in a wall
of colorful streamers so now Mario along
with Ally's repentant sister Olivia need
to flatten everything out again the
origami premise as a nice visual flair
to the already gorgeous paper crafts
look of the series and you get to see
yet another take on goombas shyguys and
Koopas even if this time they're imbued
with a slightly creepy energy like other
Paper Mario games the origami King is
less about plot and more about throwing
a joke at you at every turn whether it's
a smart turn of phrase one-off bits that
reward you for exploring its
environments with a gag or item or
extended set pieces that deliver killer
moments not every joke or bit lands but
they hit far more than they falter the
origami King is consistently sharp using
both Mario characters and its
interactivity to tell some great jokes
that's been true of the Paper Mario
series for a while now but the origami
King also manages to find new life in
its combat something the series hasn't
done in a while
moving away from the limiting and
resource dependent combat of the last
couple of entries the origami King
instead has you rearranging enemies on a
circular tile a base grid around Mario
your goal is to rotate or slide the
tiles on the grid to arrange enemies in
lines or squares making them easy to
plow through with your jumps or hammer
every encounter is essentially a time
puzzle with one or more correct
solutions and you're encouraged to solve
them quickly usually in a single churn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every fight requires just the right
amount of involvement not so simple that
you're mashing your way through them but
not so intricate that a few fights wear
you out even early on when fights
required just two clearly telegraphed
steps to solve the extra effort it takes
to arrange enemies then time your
attacks properly made me want to wade
into fights rather than avoid them as
the difficulty ramps up it's easy to
become a little too obsessed with the
solving every battle the in game timer
adds a pressure to think quickly which
occasionally clash with my perfectionist
tendencies as the difficulty ramped up I
started asking Olivia for hints which
pauses the timer or taking screenshots
if you're not bent on solving every
encounter this way I don't blame you
thankfully you can pay the crowd of
toads watching your fights to make the
first move for you and later get the
option to have encounters solved for you
entirely it's a great way to tweak the
difficulty to your mood even if I did
end up circumventing the timer in a way
that felt like cheating the effort I put
into some random encounters was better
spent on boss fights against elemental
beasts and arts and crafts tools like
coloured pencils a hole puncher or a
roll of tape which invert the flow of
combat to create intricate fights that
cap off each act with a showstopper to
fight them Mario moves to the outer
edges of the board and must move tiles
with arrows switches healing items and
attack prompts on them to deal damage
these fights are more involved in
regular battles and play out like
puzzles but there's just enough strategy
here to avoid the feeling you're
following prompts I regularly had to
choose whether I eat up precious time to
see out if I could run Mario through a
healing heart a switch to turn on a
magic circle and set circle itself in
one churn or if I should just be quick
take the risk and not heal outside
battles the origami King keeps its RPG
aspects light your main resource is gold
and while battles are your main source
of income you also get lots of it from
covering up tears in the world with
confetti fighting cannon quest in
question mark box and completing some
light side quests to get health upgrades
and money to buy weapons which wear out
over time the exploration in RPG aspects
are still somewhat shallow but the
overall sense of discovery and
progression is still rewarding enough
that I felt stronger over the course of
my playthrough and
was motivated enough to find more gold
and collectibles to comb every area you
also pick up a few party members along
the way but they're mostly an
afterthought there are a handful of
great and surprising heartfelt moments
with them but most don't stick around
long enough for you to form a bond with
them this puts a large emphasis on your
journey with Olivia across all the
origami Kings worlds and with Mario
being his usual mute self
it feels lonelier than it should it's a
concession I'm willing to take though
since just about every other part of
Paper Mario the origami King works so
well with a newfound combat system that
steals the show and offers a novel take
on turn-based combat it's winking
nodding and adventuring shine all the
brighter its world and characters might
not be the series best but it's still
able to consistently throw left turns
good gags and smart surprises at you
each piece of the origami King elegantly
fits into its hole taking its irreverent
flair to new heights the Paper Mario
series has recently shown that being
clever and being smart are two different
things
but thankfully it's once again managed
to be both
[Music]
[Music]